I have a red alert corruption story for you
today.
This is the worst of government deceit.
I previously reported to you that Dr. Rick
Bright, former deputy assistant secretary
for preparedness and response for Health and
Human Services, Dr. Rick Bright, says he was
pushed out of his role and he believes it's
because he was regularly going to the Trump
administration and saying we're unprepared
to deal with coronavirus.
He believes it's because he refused to go
out and promote the use of hydroxyl chloroquine
as a corona virus treatment.
Despite Donald Trump doing it publicly and
despite the Trump administration pushing Dr.
Rick Bright to do it, he has been working
on a whistleblower complaint, which he filed
yesterday.
It's devastating.
And we'll get to it in a moment.
But the corruption is that three days before
Donald Trump fired the inspector general of
Health and Human Services, who is the inspector
general that would have been receiving and
investigating this complaint from Dr. Rick
Bright.
Christy Grim, she was replaced with a total
Trump loyalist.
What a coincidence.
Trump couldn't stop the whistleblower complaint,
so he made sure that the person handling the
complaint, investigating the complaint would
be someone loyal to him rather than someone
whose loyalty is to the facts and to reality.
GRIMM was already on Trump's bad side because
she was willing to publish a report in January
saying, hey, we have huge shortages of PPE.
We're short on testing supplies.
If we're going to deal with a pandemic, we
are woefully unprepared.
Trump didn't like it.
And this was a great opportunity to get her
out before she had the opportunity to handle
Dr. Rick Bright's whistleblower complaint
from cleared her out.
There will be no dissension in the ranks.
Trump must be placated all the time, constantly,
or you will be fired.
So that gets us to yesterday.
Dr. Rick Bright files his whistleblower complaint.
And if even 10 percent of what's in it is
true, it is absolutely stunning.
It is everything we feared.
It's everything we've been suspecting was
going on in the Trump administration in the
lead up to the virus in December, in January.
And Dr. Rick Wright explains that early Corona
virus warnings that he brought to the administration
were ignored.
Let's check out some of what he said yesterday
during a press conference.
Time after time, I was pressured to ignore
or dismiss expert and scientific recommendation.
And instead to award lucrative contracts based
on political connections.
In other words, I was pressured to let politics
and cronyism drive decisions over the opinions
of the best scientists we have in government.
And ultimately, I was removed from my position
because of my continued insistence that the
government invest funds allocated by Congress
hard earned taxpayer dollars to address the
curb at 19 and invest and just say scientifically
that solutions.
So this is absolutely devastating.
You can listen to the six or seven minutes
during which he outlines everything that he
alleges went on.
But I'll tell you some of what it includes.
Dr. Rick Bright says he went to the administration
and said, we're short on supplies and masks.
Trump officials didn't believe him and not
enough to do anything about it.
He was right.
Of course, he says that as his warnings about
the virus were confirmed, the indifference
that he was experiencing turned to outright
hostility against him.
Dr. Rick Wright says he was pressured to give
lucrative contracts to whoever the Trump administration
wanted.
I've told you that there's been a lot of money
made on Corona virus.
And one of the ways is by getting contracts
with the government to produce PPE or other
things, sweetheart deals, as we might call
them.
Rick Bright says he's blowing the whistle.
He says, they came to me.
They told me, give the deals to these particular
companies.
And of course, we already knew.
Dr Rick Wright says he was pressured to promote
hydroxy chloroquine as a treatment for Corona
virus.
He pushed back.
He said it's not scientifically sound.
We should really limit it to these trials.
Much like a dozen other medications that we're
testing.
The Trump administration wanted chloroquine
promoted far and wide.
He refused to do it and he was transferred
out of that role.
Now, the legal argument is going to be more
complicated for Doctor Rick Bright's lawyers.
His lawyers say when he was warning the administration
about the lack of PPE and the lack of coronavirus
danger more broadly, that his actions were
protected by the Whistleblower Protection
Act.
That is a questionable case to make.
It's going to be difficult.
I mean, intuitively, certainly colloquially
it's accurate.
But the counterpoint would be he may have
been ignored when he was blowing, when he
was raising alarm, but it didn't violate the
Whistleblower Protection Act.
You could argue also that he wasn't fully
ignored, but it's going to be a difficult
case to prove.
So we have two issues here, really.
We have Dr. Rick Bright being pushed out after
being ignored.
That's tragic.
It's horrifying.
It builds on what we've suspected for some
time that the Trump administration did get
early warnings about the virus, but ignored
them at this point.
But we know that that took place in Dr. Rick
Wright was just one piece of that.
The second piece is Trump fired the person
who will be investigating Rick Bright's assertions.
What used to us are inspectors general, if
the president will just fire the ones that
actually investigate things Trump doesn't
want investigated.
Now, we could deal with that.
There is a bill that's meant to protect inspectors
general.
Two Democrats wrote it, Senator Chris Murphy
and Senator Jim Cooper.
And under this bill, the inspectors general
can't just be removed from office for political
reasons.
They could only be removed for, quote, permanent
incapacity, inefficiency, neglect of duty,
malfeasance or conviction of a felony or convict
or conduct involving moral turpitude.
That is a much higher standard than Trump
wants to stop their investigations.
So he fires them.
So we have a bill that's been written which
would deal with this.
Good luck passing it in a Republican Senate.
Which reminds us of the importance of helping
Democrats take control of the Senate in November.
Now, of course, Fox News, 0a and whoever HANNITY,
Rush Limbaugh, they're going to say about
a bill like that.
Look at these Democrats trying to prevent
bad people from being removed.
Of course, that's not what they're trying
to do.
So this is all catastrophic at every level.
And sadly, when we get to the question of
consequences, it's up to us.
I mean, listen.
What?
Who's going to do anything to Trump here?
All we can do is remove him in November.
We've got to vote this garbage of an administration
out in November because Trump's fired numerous
inspectors general.
There have been no consequences.
Trump has manipulated the people in charge
of even potentially overseeing the actions
or inactions of the federal government.
Doesn't make a difference, really.
I mean, it has not there have been no consequences.
Okay.
You know, a couple people went to prison or
are going to prison for short, short sentences.
But the big malfeasance of the constant corrupt
crony capitalism and distortions of reality
from this administration while covering.
Their misdeeds by firing people and lying
and doing all sorts of other things.
There's really been no consequence to that.
It's up to us.
It's up to us to remove this garbage.
In November, I hope that we will.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at the Packman.
Make sure you're following me there and make
sure you are signed up to the all new David
Pakman show newsletter by signing up at David
Pakman dot com